thank you very much for being on the
program it's one of those interviews
where I feel like there's so many
different places I could start there's a
lot of news but I want to start with a
thing that is almost certainly the
biggest Story the most important story
today which is inflation what's your
reaction to the figures well the Figures
were higher than expected
um markets expected them to come in a
bit lower than that that's been true for
a few months in the UK
and although they've come down what it
means is inflation has been consistently
higher than expected here for some
months is still the highest in the G7
and food inflation in particular is
still really high so what this means for
your viewers and my constituents is even
though it has dropped a little bit
prices are still Rising faster here than
any other major industrialized economy
and that's what's making it hard for
households to make ends meet
core inflation as you say in particular
much stickier than people are expecting
so things like food that obviously
impact so many people and I guess the
upshot of that is that it's more likely
that interest rates stay high or even go
higher
the one thing it feels to me that we're
not talking about enough is what that
actually means for people to have
mortgages are you worried uh I think
this is a really important part of the
picture and the conservative mini budget
last September
uh put a rocket under mortgage rates
that's when they really started to go up
quickly
and what this means for Borrowers is
that anyone coming off a two-year deal
or a five-year deal onto a new deal it
finds himself facing costs for a typical
borrower of about an extra 3 000 pounds
a year that's a huge hit to family
finances and this point you make about
inflation being sticky what you mean is
it's taking longer to come down it's
coming down more slowly that puts added
pressure on the bank of England to at
least keep interest rates higher for
longer and possibly even to have another
increase that's of course their decision
would that be a wrong decision that you
think obviously they're independent but
there is there are people who'd be
thinking like hang on a minute if this
is going to mean people not being able
to pay their bills
sure but look it's not a good idea for
politicians to start saying the bank is
right or wrong and its interest rate
decisions remember it was a labor
government that made the Bank
Independent that gave them this power
and indeed this target for inflation uh
to be at two percent so we're well off
two percent at the moment so we have
interest rates higher than they've been
for some time and it really is feeding
through to mortgage rates and people are
still paying the price for that mini
budget it's not just I mean Budget
that's it you made the point twice
it was a reckless act that booster
Rockets under mortgage rates and put
pensions on life support I want to talk
to you a little bit about Labor uh if I
may as well you're obviously in the
department where you're looking at all
the sums right
and I just wonder if there's a piece of
the picture that we're missing here
because you talk a lot about physical
responsibility not borrowing too much
making the fiscally responsible
decisions you're also talking a lot
about public services reform saying that
the current situation is broken we hear
that a lot from labor politicians you're
talking about the biggest NHS
transformation since the 1945 when it
was set up
if a labor government wants to do both
of these things
and we talk about tax Rises as well
because I think if you look at the tax
burden it's already a 70-year high
my boss Rachel Reeves is in the United
States right now and she did an
interview the other day since she was
very conscious of the size of the tax
burden so
you know we've got to make our decisions
about those if we if we'd rather in a in
a position in government but I think
we're very conscious of the size of the
tax burden and the reason we talk about
the IMF though recommending the sweet
tax rises in order to reform Public
Services well
one thing we've got the benefit of is
experience of reform in public services
the labor government I was administering
some years ago did a lot of reformer
public services and it left the NHS
with the highest satisfaction rates
since its existence we didn't do that
just by pumping in more money we did it
just by pumping we did it through a
combination of investment and reform but
that's the key there was a lot of money
as well and you're talking about
investment as well what's your view on
wealth taxes uh look all the questions
you're going to give me about individual
uh taxes will be met with the answer
that if we've got anything to announce
on tax we'll do it for the time of the
election okay but let me just not let
this point go about investment and
reform because it's really important
we're not just the preservation Society
for public services we feel we've got a
special duty to the NHS as its founder
and that Duty isn't just to save it as
sometimes people in the labor party say
but always to reform and change it and
make it fit for the future so we're
excited and interested in the
application of new technology we're
passionate about getting these waiting
lists of seven and a half million down
we have a plan which we've said who will
fund for more doctor training and more
nurse training and we've said how we'd
fund that through the abolition of the
non-dome status so it's a combination of
investment reform and that's the best
answer for the NHS um we'll wait to see
more details then as that election
approaches and Boris Johnson is in the
news agenda again I'm not I'm pretty
sure I know what your comments on that
are going to be I'm sure um we can
imagine his supporters say look he's the
guy who won a majority and he's in touch
of what people think May maybe he'll do
a better job for the conservatives than
Rishi sunak who would you be more scared
of fighting an election Boris Johnson
already seen like well if you turn
around for five minutes the Tories have
changed the leader we've had five prime
ministers in about the last it's not
quite what I asked six or seven years
um what strikes me about today's story
is two things one everything Boris
Johnson touches is a gigantic mess we've
got has he got lawyers has he not who's
paying them are they helping him are
they helping getting them reported to
the police I mean it's very difficult to
to keep track of all this the other
thing is it's always someone else's
fault it's always a plot they keep
referring to this thing called The Blob
and in my mind
The Blob has replaced Brussels in Tory
demonology they used to blame Brussels
for everything now for the Tories it's
the blob at my homework and it's always
someone else's fault and I think you
know it will never happen but it would
be nice for Boris Johnson to take
responsibility for his actions just once
who would you gone and who would you
prefer to find an election Boris Johnson
or Rishi Cena well I am
uh I like football and as I seeing in
football you can only play the team in
front of you so I really don't care who
the Tories pick we're confident that
we'll be in much better position to take
them on this time than for many years
okay
um I will allow you to have that answer
although I would say that there are some
certain football teams I prefer my team
to face than others
um thank you very much for being on the
show thank you